هذا هون هي جزيره المتاحف هذه هون يعني كل
المتاحف معظمنا هون
بلش هون عرفت
جديد اللي
بيكون كل متاحف الاحم متاحف بالمركز واحد
بحكي كل التاريخ من اول الحضور هدارات الى
الحديث من اشك قديم الى المعسكر
الرابط
بشكل اوسع الى اوروبا جميل المتحف
الاسلامي هو بالناحيه الثانيه حلم الفكره
انه المتاحف في بنفس المحيط يعني الزائر
ما بياخذ مسافات بعيده بيزورهم كلهم بوقت
يعني متقارب بعدين حاله هون كمان روماني
عيوناني
بلدان العالميه انت تحب تحب الشرق كتير
سوريا ولبنان
عشتنا
تزوجت منها
وهلا اطفالي لازم يحكموا بالعمل كمان شوف
المعالم الحرب
هذا الحرب العالميه الثانيه
هذا رصاص هتلر ولا ستالين
[ضحك]
بالقتل والحروب والتدمير لم
يتعلموا وما راح يتعلموا
بس المهم انه نقدر نحكي هيدا وظيفتنا
الحمد لله هون متى فينا نحكي شوي من القصه
انه المعرفه دائما بيجي بالشبكه بين الناس
ومش من شعب لحاله